The Joe Rogan Experience let's split the
difference I can't sell out uh Madison
Square Garden but I think I could sell
out the Dwayne Reed next to it so let's
go there maybe we'll stop a smash and
grab that'll be great we can kill two
birds of one stone I saw a smash and
grab today on uh on YouTube it was wild
they just went into this uh store and
started ripping cell phones off the
walls it's definitely not Ocean's 11.
these kids they're freestyling it race
and they're all wearing masks which
you're allowed to wear now uh-huh
you like made wearing masks okay so
everyone's wearing a mask and they're
just running in there and stealing [ __ ]
this is this stuff is like honestly it's
like I never thought this was going to
be on the other side of this but the
thing that's really getting me now and I
think you probably will agree is that
like you know I don't know I hate to be
hacky and Duke kind of a joke but it's
like I didn't know as Americans we have
the right to like go to a fast food
place if there's something wrong we can
hop the counter and beat a man to death
like I didn't know that whatever
happened to just eating what you get or
walking away like if somehow this is
like some kind of Honor killing you have
to confront this man this poor kid this
poor kid making uh seven bucks an hour
you have to confront him and like you
know whatever it's ridiculous I never
thought I would see that it really blows
me away there's nothing like a late
night Fast Food Barn brawl well this is
not like a punch-up like hey what's up
what did you say to me at the rodeo you
know hey this is like Full Tilt like but
those barn burner brawls where people
like everybody's piling on top of
everybody and smashing like a bar room
brawl like an okay Corral an okay Corral
fight at a you know a 2 A.M uh Waffle
House or something you know the IHOP
everyone's favorite throw down joint
there's something about getting drunk
people late at night in those [ __ ]
places
and the poor people that worked there
honestly it's like it's like they should
be getting combat pay you know when you
see a brawl at a [ __ ] Waffle House if
you work there like every other day and
and the people who do work there are
like Shell Shocked they're like a
thousand yards there it's like what are
you having you know they're like looking
like checking the corners
how about how about just the fact that
like there's no late night food anymore
everything closes early people are
afraid to stay open yeah there's this
one the guy who had the ax he pulled an
ax out of his bed yeah that was in New
York that's one of ours this guy took
all these punches why is he getting beat
up I don't know what happened it's like
the same normal thing you know like a
fight at McDonald's then he pulls out
the ass oh yeah yes I'm from New York
the axe man
you can get them at Home Depot that
might be said he might be in trouble
might be
that seems like not good but he did show
a little bit of restraint letting those
dudes punch him yeah no it was the whole
thing was like that's all you got he
kept saying because of that but [ __ ]
that's just another day in New York the
Wawa in Philadelphia oh yeah see that
video it's hilarious this lady goes are
you gonna make sandwiches are you just
gonna keep recording them she wants her
sandwich can you believe it this is
behind the counter and she's so
non-plussed by this chaos behind her
she's like are you guys gonna make
sandwiches are you just gonna keep
recording them I want a [ __ ] sandwich
see I don't care about this that's
amazing because uh like when you're not
from Philly you love a Wawa you're like
man this is such a so much better than
7-Eleven it's so much better than
everything and then for them to
desecrate it like that oh it's the
craziest uh like group activity in a a
store that I've ever seen because they
all just decided to go nuts it's a small
amount of people a lot of [ __ ] people
and they just grab and [ __ ] off the
shelves and throwing [ __ ] on the ground
this is this girl yes she wants she just
wants a sandwich
but at least she beat the line you know
why everybody's distracted
oh my God this is so crazy where's my
penalty police said they found
approximately 100 juveniles inside the
Wawa but made no arrests why would you
arrest somebody I mean why am I making a
rest it happened to me when I was at a
7-Eleven here just one guy though he I
was going to walk to pay for like a
Snickers bar or something and as I was
going to walk up he just grabbed
something and walked right out lady's
like
it seemed like it happened on the
nightly case like a nightly basis
I'm sure people just steal things now
because it in certain places like in San
Francisco if you don't steal 900 bucks
worth of stuff they don't even do
anything they don't yeah it has to be
more than 900 bucks worth of stuff so
people are going in there and just
stealing whatever the [ __ ] they want as
long as it's not 900 bucks worth they
just leave in in New York like like that
happened so much that like you'll see it
happen and then like they'll try and be
very like woke about it like you know
hey you know people need things whatever
and then you'll see the same guy from
the news selling this stuff like on the
street like walking down you need some
Tide you need some Tide because they're
trying to make some money but at the end
of the day that store will go out of
business like they'll shut it down right
I mean they are a company they got to
make money right so five people lost
their jobs you know there's no there's
no neighborhood store now for people to
get so the whole idea of like you know
no one's really getting hurt with this
it's not true it's really it's really
incredible to see how bad it is you know
it's a wild time Dave it is wild times
they really are wild and uh you know I
feel like I'm too old to boost you know
like I don't have it in me anymore
[Music]
when you when you uh see were you around
in New York in the 90s when it was crazy
in Times Square yeah is it like that to
you or worse I think that um uh maybe
because I'm older and I'm a homeowner
now you know like you know I'm like what
is going on here kids yeah these kids
but I I think that this is just a sense
of entitlement of people allowed to do
whatever they want to do whenever they
want to do it like driving like mopeds
on the sidewalk doing all that kind of
stuff you know hey if I feel like uh you
know driving erratically I'm gonna do it
if I feel like walking down the street
holding like a piece of metal and
yelling at people I'm gonna do it
because it's more of a
hands-off kind of scene in New York now
you know like basically like we're not
going to get involved until like
actually something happens so you know
uh uh uh if if you got like young kids
or business or something like that you
really are in a bad place at the wrong
time you know like outdoor dining there
and guys come up and just start
screaming at you rip something off your
table you know that kind of thing I
always tell the tourists that come this
is like oh watch out and I'll go like
you know the way you're holding your bag
don't hold it like that it's too easy
you know like put it this way they get a
little like like whoa I didn't know it
was like that and the subway is a whole
different world down there you know
that's like you know it's always wild
yeah the Subway's wild it's wild to be
contained did you see the video of henzo
Gracie getting in a fight on the subway
that was cool he said he [ __ ] his knee
up I ran into him like oh he did yeah
I'm ran into him like I guess a week and
a half or so later talk about a great
situation for what he does and you're
like that's it exactly you know what a
terrible move by that guy
let's tell them to speak English he's
like my friend you know he did the right
thing though right he's like trying to
de-escalate he didn't even hurt him he
just threw him to the ground and
controlled him and put him in a
Stranglehold and let him go right and
told him to apologize well uh I don't
know if he knows right there like out of
all the people to [ __ ] with you [ __ ]
with henzo Gracie that's such a huge
mistake he just controlled him the dude
was trying to punch him and henzo's on
top of him he's like no son you're not
going anywhere heading Arm Control half
guard puts a smush down on him
and he's strangling them right now
wow
it's just a terrible terrible mistake
oh my God thank God yeah that would have
been so scary that would have been
pushing people on the track [ __ ] hearing
about that kind of stuff like yeah yeah
that's New York man that's just the way
it is there's a lot of towns like that
now just like where it's like oh I guess
that's the way it is have you been to
Portland lately or no Portland's wild
yeah huh Portland is so weird that like
um The Helium Club they're very cool
Club you know and that neighborhood is
kind of like it's like the warehouse Art
District or something like that and you
know they have serious like housing
problem there it's very sad and all that
stuff but I talked to somebody who like
uh you know like whatever who lives
there and I go so uh these people are
allowed to you know put up like whatever
they want wherever they want he goes
yeah and they they really you know like
the sad thing is like fires you know
like something will happen and like yeah
you know it could uh catch fire so
they're cooking meth in a tent uh could
be yeah cooking meth in a little plastic
house will go wrong so it's like talk
about like you know I don't know like
you didn't see that coming no no one saw
that coming I didn't see it someone just
filmed it the other day and sent it to
me that they were in Portland and showed
me this road they went down all the the
tents how crazy it is and how dense it
is it's like wow you're not gonna do
anything about that you're just gonna
let that happen
it doesn't seem like a [ __ ] safety
hazard a public safety hazard a health
hazard all the above hazards it's isn't
it litter it's also litter it's litter
it's like in New York they have the
outdoor dining have you seen these
things yeah it's like it's like cabooses
like it's like a Manger you know it's
like it's like basically it's like you
know you might as well do a reenactment
in there you know but like they were
having like people having sex in there
and all because they were all making
jokes about it and everything like that
but it's like why wouldn't they it's
like too tempting I mean like why
wouldn't you there's no one in there
with you you gotta you know like
Christen it basically you know make it
your own but it's just like filthy and I
don't know I guess you know if people
really want the grunge of New York
you're seeing it right now
do you still enjoy living there no but
uh have you thought about bailing I
can't I can't because of my mom you know
I gotta be close